hello everyone i'm alexander rose the
executive director here at long now i'm
so excited to have so many member
speakers with us today for this ignite
format the ignite format was co-founded
by brady forrest who's also going to be
our host today with that i'll hand it
off to brady welcome brady forest
thanks xander it's uh it's really great
to be back here at the long now this is
our third
ignite with the lung now where we bring
in members and
ignite
is designed to be a place where
everybody gets to speak every one of
these speakers gets five minutes on zoom
with 20 slides 15 seconds to slide
so
it is ideal for someone who is a
beginning speaker but it is also the
type of thing that can elevate an
advanced speaker and uh i think you'll
see a lot of that today
so please welcome our first speaker
talking about
nature
and how it will work
within our cities
she is an archaeologist and professor at
ucla
take it away monica l smith
today we might be focused on the long
now
but what about the long ago
what are the archaeological
paleontological
and geological sources
of the dust to which we will all return
or perhaps we're focused on the
anthropocene
because it makes humans sound so
important to have a geologic era named
after us
or maybe we're focused on the
intersection
between nature
and culture
the things that we surround with the
linearity
the ways that we bound nature to our
will
in ways that say
watch out
something important is happening here
for humans
i'm an archaeologist and people are
always asking me
where does the dirt come from
why are archaeologists always
digging
and i ask them in return
why are you always
sweeping
because an archaeological site begins
when the last person
puts down their broom
and walks away
and those spaces
in our built environment
are the places where nature
reinserts itself
subtly in the interstices
where new geologic layers can come from
anything
from pollen
from dust
from bird droppings
even
flowers
and these places in the interstices that
you might not have noticed until just
now
are places that i started photographing
a few years ago when i started thinking
about where archaeological sites
come from
most sites do not disappear overnight
like pompeii
they disappear in increments of dust
like a rook
or jericho
or mohenjodaro
or maybe they disappear in the tendrils
of vegetation
that subtly overwhelm the built
environment places like tikal
or angkhor or yasha
and in those linearities of human
intention
where the plants grow
there are many more species of plants
than there are species
of human
and that archaeology is what becomes
incrementally
in the spaces that we thought we had
designed for ourselves
but where nature and the plants
were waiting to take over
it might appear
as though nature conforms itself to the
spaces
where we allow
it but don't be fooled
it's just waiting to put in
some spaces
those unruly places
the little spots
where the dust and the dirt and the
plant seeds
come in
it is as though nature is taking the
opportunity
to contrast itself
with the linearity that we offer in our
built environment
just
waiting
to implant itself
in the places
that we thought we controlled
like a dandelion
masquerading his intentionality
these are not
derelict places
some of these images are from the most
expensive zip code in america
some of them are just a few feet away
from one of the busiest
intersections in the country
and these places where we think we have
controlled
places where we put in
a classification
of space
of places that are curated
or planted
or free
are places where nature itself
is just
biding its time
to come back to that
sinuous
intersection
is it distressing or comforting to know
how the anthropocene ends
in every contest
large or small nature
always
wins
thank you
i certainly see it winning all over san
francisco on a daily basis
where do you see it in la
everywhere under foot now that you've
seen it you'll see it everywhere in the
steps in the cracks of the sidewalks
even in the traces of the freeway i see
now little bits of vegetation along the
medians and the margins even though
there are thousands of wheels passing an
hour nature is still
there
thank you for that meditation
it was great to have you here monica
and next up
we are joined by an american artist
who's
thinking of new rituals
please welcome
the creative director of jumpstar
george farandi
as an artist who spent most of my life
in east coast cities i never really saw
the stars until i spent some time in the
mountains where the night sky was so
spectacular i bought a book by h.a and
margaret ray to help me understand what
i was seeing
in it i learned about axial precession
a very slow wobble in earth's rotation
that means
while our polar axis currently points to
polaris in a thousand years it will
point to another star
in other words our literal and
figurative guiding light our north star
which has come to symbolize the single
thing that never changes will change
but of course it will the universe is
change
what i want to know is how will we
commemorate that change
we have a huge party every time the
earth makes one rotation around the sun
fancy clothes sparkly drinks we lament
the past predict the future
for an event that happens every year
surely there'll be an unforgettable
celebration to acknowledge the star that
for centuries led ships to shore and
enslaved people to freedom
who will write the songs for that
occasion will the un organize a
committee will nasa
who will plan the party to say goodbye
to our north star and when will they
start
which begs the question
what if it's us
and what if we start now
and this is the premise of jumpstart
a multi-disciplinary initiative that
brings artists musicians and scientists
together with communities to invent
traditions that can be passed through
the generations to say goodbye to
polaris and hello to gamma c phi
the whole project is named in honor of
annie jump cannon the remarkable def
harford astronomer who established our
star classification system which was
officially adopted 100 years ago this
week
and the way it works is through a series
of dream storming workshops we call
constellates
each consulate is dedicated to
researching and inventing one aspect of
future culture
a song a healing ceremony a celebratory
snack
for our dance consulate in kansas for
example
local performers working in a range of
styles each contributed a gesture that
our choreographer then incorporated into
an experimental version of a barn dance
which is a style beloved in that
particular region
for our future foods consulate our
climatologist explains how climate
change will affect what agriculture will
be viable in the region in a thousand
years and then participants work with
local chefs to invent new recipes using
those ingredients like cricket flour to
make chocolate chirp cookies
i've been researching all the stars that
are in our cycle of future north stars
and have developed characters for each
of them based on how they're described
by various cultures through history
and then with communities around the
country i'm designing and building
ceremonial sculptures to represent these
future north stars
using a technique traditional in a
japanese festival called nebuta which
was itself once a star festival
the sculptures have lightweight wooden
armatures and wire frames with paper
skins and they're illuminated from the
inside clockwise from the left is deneb
the indestructibles theta buddhists aka
boots thuben and vega
and they're all designed to be danced by
teams of community participants we call
dark matter since dark matter is what
holds up the stars here we have polaris
gamma sipha rock bogathi shemalai
alfawares and alderamin
and they were all to be part of
jumpstar's inaugural ceremony in kansas
but they haven't had the premiere yet a
few hours after our rehearsal and these
photos a tornado destroyed the
surrounding tents somehow our tent and
the very fragile paper sculpture
survived unscathed
but only the dark matter volunteers have
ever seen them in person
so we're still inventing the celebration
and wondering where the first ever
jumpstart ceremony will be
but we're not wondering why it's
important
it can be easier to imagine apocalypse
than to look to the future with hope
but as the long now community knows
our visions for the future
are the very tools that will help us
build it
jumpstart offers the promise of a party
and the celestial moment as playful
strategies for forging those tools with
the questions
what do we need to repair and prepare in
the present before we can host the
future
how do we get our house in order before
the holiday
it lets us look forward with love to the
resilience of civilizations of the
future
take action to ensure them a livable
world
and plan the party that will celebrate
their survival
thank you so much for listening and
thank you to the long now for presenting
thank you george
when you were
creating this ritual
what are some of the ideas that you
discarded
oh my gosh
well
the the whole project kind of grows from
the inside out
and so
what makes it
to the table is what has
meaning to the people in the room
so
what what i select or discard isn't as
important as kind of what we come to
by consensus in each of the communities
all right well thank you for being with
us today george
thanks so much brady
all right
and
now to talk about scientific revolutions
is industrial artist matthew dockery
take it away
hey
so in
1665 the world's oldest scientific
journal philosophical transaction
started publication
and for the last year i've been working
on a project where i read them starting
with issue number one
i dig up all the historical context i
can for the articles put it together
make a video about it and post it
it's been a lot of work but also a lot
of fun and
i've learned some stuff that i thought i
would share with you here
so it was a project of the royal society
of london one of their first big
projects actually
and their secretary henry oldenburg
had long been the center of a kind of
scientific pen pal network spanning
europe
and the journal was really a
formalization of that
it saved him the effort of handwriting
out all the copies i suppose
he mostly saw it as a way to make money
on the side but well unfortunately for
him that never worked very well
uh but it worked pretty well for
everyone else but to really understand
philosophical transactions you have to
go back even further in this earlier in
the century to francis bacon he was a
mildly corrupt court official who was
absolutely convinced that
academics had been doing everything
wrong for centuries if you wanted to
learn about the world you had to do
experiments you couldn't just sit around
and think about it really hard
in his book the new organon he very
explicitly says that we need to move
away from deductive reasoning and
embrace inductive reasoning instead
the uh the old satire about angels on
the head of a pen well he didn't write
it but it was from his time and he
probably would have approved he even
wrote a story called the new atlantis
about a fictional island kingdom at the
center of which is solomon's house
which to a modern eye can only really be
described as a research institute they
gather knowledge about the world study
it and use it as the basis for further
experiments
and by following this technique the
fictional kingdom has gained some really
amazing technological powers including
well what we would call televisions and
submarines and recorded music it's an
oddly prophetic book in a lot of ways
but this was still a very
centralized very top-down understanding
of science
bacon thought that the project should be
first to collect all the facts about the
world natural histories on fire and air
and birds and everything and once you've
done that it would probably only be the
project of a couple years for people to
go through and look at it all and figure
out the rules and how the world works
well this was convincing enough that
several decades later some people were
really trying to make it happen
the royal society grew out of a series
of public lectures at gresham college
some public lectures not too unlike
these actually
and they were very explicitly trying to
start
solomon's house and a big part of that
would be tools of communication which is
where the journal came in
now the first couple decades were pretty
rough they started just in time for the
plague
and then they got back from that just in
time for the great fire and then
oldenburg was thrown into the tower
under suspicion of being a dutch spy
but it was also rough because they
didn't know what they were doing and
that's really the joy out of reading the
early issues is that you get to see them
inventing the very concept of scientific
publication from issue to issue
the contents were also rough and kind of
a mixed bag um you get the earliest
recorded
um record of the great red spot of
jupiter and it's next to a description
of a deformed head of a monstrous calf
there are book reviews and trip reports
and a lot of descriptions of mining
technology
but for me one of the other big joys is
getting to see how different
the actual process of the scientific
revolution was
compared to the stories we tell about it
today
so take astronomy as an example there
are a lot of articles about cometary
motion and many of them end with a note
to the effect that maybe this will help
settle the grand question of the earth's
motion
now remember we are 120 years after
copernicus at this point and 30 years
after galileo those kind of paradigm
shifts really have a much longer tail
than history books usually indicate to
us
when we're learning science it's a very
sanitized version with all the dead ends
removed and presenting a nice linear
narrative
but real science is messy and petty and
weird and it always has been
now the glory of science is that it
works even despite that but they didn't
know that at the time they really
thought they were forming
uh solomon's house and would just sort
of dispassionately argue about the facts
and do experiments and instead they got
confusion and infighting and a distinct
lack of decorum
but they still generated the greatest
engine for the development of knowledge
the world had ever seen it wasn't what
they intended but it worked
and the communication of scientific
results to the journal was a really
integral part of that
by scaling up oldenburg's pen pal
network they turned it into something
completely different it had made the
private public and it lets science be
more than just a hobby for rich weirdos
and that's at least something i'm very
thankful for
so basically the scientific method works
despite who's
doing it
exactly
um and i we're just kind of lucky that
they let it keep going even though it
really failed to live up to so many of
their ideals beforehand
which is your uh
favorite story from back then
oh um
there was this amazing exchange between
robert hook
and this french astronomer adrian azu
and hook had just published his
magnificent book micrographia which is
just filled with these amazing
illustrations the flea in these slides
is from that it's a pretty famous image
but as also part of the book like he got
a chance to write a book so he was going
to put in everything he could and one of
the things he shoved in there was this
idea he had for how to improve lens
grinding there's a whole new mechanism
for doing it
but he'd never actually tried it he just
like here's what i think would work and
azure writes into the journal saying
this really doesn't live up to our grand
baconian ideals of basing everything on
personal experience and experimentation
and hook just loses it at that uh with
some amazing vitriolic attacks and
response including an amazing argument
that the zoo was really the hypocrite
because azu hadn't done an experiment to
prove the device wouldn't work um and to
me that just really summarizes just how
quickly things got pretty nasty actually
and that's not even course getting into
the more famous disputes between uh
newton and others later in the century
if someone wanted to read like a book on
this topic what would you recommend
oh that is a very good question um
i don't remember the name of it off the
top of my head i'm sorry um there's one
i'm thinking of
uh
and it's sitting behind me somewhere
well
we'll follow up later and share it in
the show notes i will do thank you very
much matthew thank you
and now
to deliver a very timely talk
i'd like to welcome fayette snyder derek
thanks brady hello my name is leia
snyderich and i am writing a novel set
in the future
for my novel i'm researching ectogenesis
which is my topic for today
ectogenesis is the development of a
mammalian embryo in an artificial
environment
so since i'm a writer i'm going to tell
you a story as a way to explain it and
it begins in the year
2052
kanye kirchhoff is a pregnant 40 year
old phd candidate
she wants to finish her thesis before
her child is born
the title of her thesis is
ectogenesis
is it as easy as one two three
at almost two months pregnant kanye
writes a very strong chapter on the
first researchers to successfully grow
these lambs in bio bags from the human
equivalent of 23 weeks to full term
kanye wonders how she's going to weave
in when private funding started she
cites this tweet from elon musk who's
worried about population collapse and an
advertising ceo's response synthetic
looms
kanya's ring vibrates and she switches
on her vr and walks into her doctor's
appointment
although natural birth is still
technically legal
kanye's doctor is shocked to see a
six-week-old embryo on the ultrasound
in year 2052 it is barbaric to suffer
through pregnancy her doctor reminds her
of the safety of ectogenesis and the
equality among genders and sexual
minorities that it's given the world
this is all true but kanye just finished
a chapter of the long ago cesarean
section
that increased at an alarming rate not
because of improved outcomes but because
of legal and economic conditions of the
time was it just yesterday that kanye
opened her feet to see womb tech stock
increased 50 percent
kanye's friends enjoyed watching their
fetuses grow on the live stream
but once they picked up their babies at
the wombtech warehouses they still
struggled with
age-old issues like
um
affordable health care and child care
and equal division of domestic labor
nonetheless
her friends were surprised that kanye
decided to go against the mainstream
they asked her if she thought her body
would remember how to give birth they
told her that she was brave
kanye tried to remember when public
opinion started to shift and she found
this date in 2021
when the international society for stem
cell research lifted the 14-day limit on
human embryo research kanye wrote about
the first ex-uro machines to grow mouse
fetuses with a heartbeat not much
different from the ones developed by
wombtech today
but in 2030 public opinion really
shifted with these machines that started
saving millions of premature infants as
early as 23 weeks
maybe kanye was an outlier but she
thought her friends were the brave ones
until synthetic eggs past clinical
trials the eggs supporting wombtech inc
were extracted from human bodies
how many injections did her friends
agree to
was it 60 hours of procedures and
doctor's visits
kanya wasn't convinced that
ectogenesis was as easy as one two three
as unpopular as it was
kanye wanted a natural birth
she wanted the benefits to her brain and
her child's brain and she really just
wanted people to trust her ability to
make good decisions for herself
as her pregnancy became noticeable
social and legal pressures increased her
doctor threatened to call child
protective services unless she
transitioned her pregnancy to an
artificial womb
so kanya was forced to hide which proved
very productive for her writing she
completed her thesis and when her baby
was born she described it as
pure reverence
back at work
kanya breast fed in the meditation room
a gift in 2052
that less than one percent
of people could give their children
thank you so much
thank you so much um
what did you see as the relation between
this talk and your book
yeah so the inspiration um for my book
was uh
this new science coming out and a
imaginary vision of
a warehouse
full of
babies growing in
artificial wombs
so
i wrote from that
visual
all right
well thank you very much for being with
us today theath
thank you brady
and next up please welcome a professor
from university of amherst
sandy litchfield
thank you brady i'm happy to be here
uh so i work as an artist and a curator
and an assistant professor associate
professor sorry i just got tenure
at
university of massachusetts and amherst
i teach courses that lie at the
intersection of art architecture design
and writing
this project began in response to a
series of questions first if mistakes
are gifts we give ourselves to learn
then what will we learn collectively
from the mistakes that we as a
civilization are making now
and what will civilization even look
like in a thousand years
finally how can artists writers
scientists and other informed
imaginarians come together and help
shape a future in which civilization is
understood as a fully entwined
terrestrial entity
on distinct keys is a transdisciplinary
platform for generating speculative
futures in the wake of climate change
with a virtual twist and playful shake
it attempts to confront and reckon with
the precarious nature of our planet's
future
as sea levels rise and coastal shores
flood on distinct keys imagines the
birth and rise of a new baby island
the island begins as a volcanic sea
mount deep in the north atlantic
in a massive volcanic eruption the sea
mount breaks the ocean surface in the
year 2066.
life shows up pretty quickly after that
and within a thousand years of evolution
there are rivers and lakes settlements
and cities and forests and
farms now in this future tale places are
the main characters
they are sentient beings that have
rights
and they are intricately entwined with
all the organic and mineral elements
that inhabit it including humans animals
insects
tree moss and stone
the stories emerge from a practice
called futuring
so what is futuring
futuring is an informed act of the
imagination
it is plural there is not one feature
there are many
it is democratic and inclusive of many
voices from around the world
featuring is also playful it's open and
it's adaptable
but it's at the same time very
analytical and aware it collects and
analyzes information from the past
present to create stories about possible
probable and preferred futures
the process of featuring and now allows
for the intuitive it emphasizes the
atmospheric and the ambient over
certainty and solution this essential
ambiguity maintains a kind of mystery in
the process
the project has two platforms for
storytelling there's the fabula which is
a future fiction set in the year 3000
and the chronica which is a diagrammatic
timeline that extends from 1000 to 3000
ce
the fabula is a non-linear narrative
that is more poetic and spatial and it
takes the form as of a map depicting
this future island called andaka
the chronica
which is a word that comes from kronos
which means the personification of time
is a more linear and sequential mode of
storytelling
now when you're piecing together past
and future events in a timeline
you would think that the past events
would be much more
evident and objective than the future
ones
but actually they're both stories with
various degrees of data and facts to
support them
even the present is a story that we
construct from our perceptions our
observations and our interpretations of
what is both known and
unknown
this project seeks to uncover those
stories by assembling a diverse team of
scholars artists designers writers and
activists who engage in this practice of
featuring
here we tell stories
by listening to our past and future
selves the future island
the future ocean the future river
we draw pictures and we tell stories
of our becoming
how shall we become the lake
and the forest
how shall we become the city that lives
with the forest and the ocean and the
whale
and how can we extend the notion of
civility
to include the ecosystem
as the orchard watesy describes
it's an unreasonable season
full of reckless pollination
but if this feverish field of folly can
inoculate the poppy with a veritable
palm
you will find the nerve to stand at the
edge of green
and go
thank you
thank you sandy
using fiction has always been a great
way to make the future what's your
favorite sci-fi or future looking book
um i really like ursula k le guins
always coming home
um and i also like octavia butler's um
parable of the sewer those are really my
two favorite
thank you very much for being with us
today cindy
happy to be here
and here to talk about landscapes
is jose julio
rodriguez
gracias
[Music]
[Music]
contemporaneous
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
mexico
[Music]
is
thank you so much for doing that for us
and would you mind sharing what's your
favorite volcanic landscape
[Music]
is
and now joining us from down under
please welcome adam long take it away
hello from australia and yes with a last
name like long it was nominated
determinism that i would be here with
the long now foundation
have you ever wondered why it is when
somebody sneezes everybody immediately
says bless you even if they're not
religious even if they don't know the
person even if they're somewhere
inappropriate like a cinema and the
reason that happens is because of a
story that was told hundreds of years
ago that a sneeze was the soul escaping
and bless you pushes it back in
stories influence our behavior they
change the way we think and the way we
interact with the world
but in the modern world stories are
being told mainly by this group
marketers just ask naomi klein because
marketers are putting so much effort
into repeating stories over and over
again they're infiltrating our psyche
our culture and our very infrastructure
so today i want to take you through
three examples of how marketers have
really ruined along now that's right
they've taken some stories and done some
real damage with how those stories have
spread
we'll start by going back to the 1920s
here's a typical street scene in the
1920s for new york the street was a
place for people to
live play commerce socialize and then
came the car suddenly the streets
started to get dangerous and as
pedestrian deaths mounted
public outcry grew a couple of states
got together and said let's put some
speed limiters on this confounding
contraption so they can't go faster than
15 miles an hour
now the motor industry didn't like the
sounds of that they wanted to drive fast
so they came up with a solution
these guys
now in australia would call them a bogan
some call them hex some call them yokels
but at the time they called them jays
jays was someone who came from the
countryside and didn't know how to act
in the city
they became the first jaywalkers
and the idea of jaywalking is that
instead of people dying because of
reckless drivers people are dying
because of reckless pedestrians
that term that story has changed the
very fabric of our cities not just
blaming the pedestrians for their deaths
but also deciding where people can and
can't walk who's at fault when something
happens
can you imagine if the story was
different and we talked about jay
drivers instead of jay walker's what
might our cities look like with a
different story
now around the same time in the 20s
tobacco companies noticed that there
weren't as many women as men who were
smoking only 3 percent of women were
smokers while nearly 60 of men were so
they hired a pr firm led by someone
called edward bernays who happened to be
the nephew of sigmund freud
like all good marketers he looked for
influences who will the market look up
to now at the time suffragettes were in
full swing in first wave feminism these
were the people that women were looking
up to so he teamed up with them and at
the easter parade of 1927 he got women
to light cigarettes and call them
tortures of freedom
turning the act of lighting and smoking
a cigarette from a dirty habit into
something underpinning feminism
now if that's not a compelling story i
don't know what is who wouldn't want to
support feminism
but the damage was done you can see that
by the time this started came through
eight times as many women were smoking
as there were in 1927 when that first
story around cigarettes being tortured
for freedom first infiltrated our
culture
now do you want to accept this cookie
probably you do i expect you accept many
every single day and this is another
example where perhaps just using a
different term a different story for
cookies we'd end up somewhere different
now the term cookies was invented by lou
montelli based on fortune cookies where
some code was trapped inside some other
code and hidden
but what it means is that these cookies
infiltrate and extract our data they
follow us around the internet and if you
think we're protected by privacy
policies well on the left there you can
see the pink one is instagrams i'm sure
we all read and agreed to that one and
on the right you can see just how much
data when printed facebook collects on a
single individual
so the question i have for you is what
would our state of privacy look like if
instead of calling them cookies we
called them something else maybe creepy
tracking code that watches you just like
someone watching you walk around a mall
perhaps our attitudes to privacy would
be very very different
but there is hope because knowing that
stories can do damage means we can also
elevate the stories that do help and
there have been plenty of examples of
those throughout history as well there's
the wave of uh minimalism which has
really been championed by the likes of
patagonia saying don't buy this jacket
or think of all the stories that were
told to make germ theory a reality and
get people to start doing things as
simple as washing their hands or think
about the movement of social enterprises
that are turning what people wear into a
statement for what they believe in
like consciousness my own company so
there is hope as long as we're mindful
and choiceful about the stories we tell
we can shape the long now for the better
don't let the marketers do more damage
thanks adam
uh
i'm wondering do you see any examples of
a
potential marketing
ruin happening right now one that we
won't see the effects of for a long time
oh
yeah they're coming in in all the time
aren't they uh there's a question around
will the metaverse be an equivalent to
the world we live in outside for example
uh there are stories around whether our
our destiny uh lies in space or whether
our destiny is solving the the problems
here so that that's an interesting one
the fault the false dichotomy saying do
we go to space or do we fix the problems
here on earth uh the marketers need to
solve that one and get people thinking
long term
and not get distracted by the short-term
thinking
all right
well thanks for joining us adam
thank you very much glad to be here
now please welcome bay area artist linda
gas take it away
thank you for having me here
this is a story about how an
experimental temporary land art
installation turned into a permanent
living artwork through the power of
community engagement
i'm an environmental activist and an
artist and i combine the two to make
artwork about climate change water and
land use
my approach is to use beauty to
encourage people to look at the hard
issues we face
i'm inspired by the connections between
humans and the water and the land that
we need to survive
several years ago i was awarded an
artist residency and i ventured outside
of my comfort zone to create create a
community engaged artwork in a new open
space park in a low income racially and
culturally diverse city in the san
francisco bay area
the open space park is called cooley
landing and it's located in the city of
east palo alto
this is a bird's eye view of coulee
landing today but this peninsula of land
hasn't always been here
200 years ago the area was lush wetlands
but from 1932 to 1960 those wetlands
were filled with garbage when it was a
san mateo county landfill
lead mercury pcbs and other toxins were
all dumped here
today coulee landing is a new public
park the toxic landfill has been capped
with six feet of clean soil native
species have returned and they're
thriving and there's a beautiful new
education center
i invited the local community to
participate in creating a temporary land
art installation at cooley landing to
mark the former shoreline of the
wetlands with blue plastic survey
whiskers the plan was to leave the
installation there for a month
i used this united states coastal survey
map of san francisco bay from 1857
to locate the former shoreline of cooley
landing
you can see the pier that was the
original coulee landing surrounded by
extensive wetlands
by placing this map over a recent
satellite image i could locate the
former shoreline relative to the present
day features the placement of the
installation is highlighted in blue and
it avoids habitat areas for endangered
species
on installation days i marked the former
shoreline with orange flagging tape
and then the community placed the blue
survey whiskers along this line by
hammering them into the ground with five
inch nails
and people of all ages participated
here's a view of part of the final
installation the entire artwork is over
500 feet long and used 2 000 survey
whiskers the community loved it and
asked if i could create a permanent
installation but without the plastic
i thought it would be really cool to
replace the survey whiskers with native
plants but i had no idea what to plant
so i consulted a local restoration
nonprofit and they suggested native
juncus
and together we created a new project
called the living shoreline
juncus is a reed that's blue green in
color and it grows upright so it was a
perfect replacement for the blue plastic
survey whiskers it also has very good
long-term survival characteristics it's
drought tolerant and it grows in meadow
or wetland environments
cooley landing in nearby east palo alto
are vulnerable to the impact of sea
level rise so the adaptability of juncus
is important
as a wetland plant it helps reduce the
impact to sea level rise by absorbing
rising tides
over the past five years community
volunteers have helped to plant and
maintain the junkists
on weekends individuals and families
came out to plant
and many return to check on how it's
grown
during the week we invited
school classrooms to participate they
ranged in age from kindergarteners to
high school students i was touched to
see these young children so focused on
planting the junkist they were so
careful and gentle with the plants
we also worked with high school students
from six different local high schools
and we spent three hours giving them
hands-on experience with wetlands
restoration sea level rise science and
land art and everyone got to plant some
junkis
this is the installation a year after it
was planted i want to give a shout out
to my partners in this project
grassroots ecology the mid-peninsula
regional open space district and the
city of east palo alto and thanks to the
palo alto arts center as well the other
day i was looking at cooley landing in
google earth and i realized that the
installation is now visible from space
it's been really rewarding to
collaborate with the community and with
living plants
at this point nature is in charge of the
artwork and the junkist continues to
mature as you can see in this recent
photo if you like this project and want
to see more visit my website or find me
on social media
thank you so very much for this
opportunity to share this with you
linda thank you so much for being with
us today
what uh can you share another
of your favorite natural art pieces
that's a really good question this is
actually the first one that i've done
with plants i've done other land art
installations in the landscape using
textiles
and i really love collaborating with the
other species of plants so i want to do
more of that
if someone wanted to do a similar
project
how should they approach it
well
it's really important to get the
community buy-in i did a lot of
presentations at city council meetings
and
collaborating with these different
government agencies in order to make it
happen
and so i think that's the most important
part and then also really understanding
the appropriateness of the plants that
you're using for the environment that
you're working in you don't want
something that's going to
uh take over
another landscape
you want it to be compatible with that
yeah so first community then plants
yes all right
well cool thank you so much linda
oh thanks for having me this is so nice
to be here
and now i'd like to welcome back a
veteran ignite speaker
take it away jason crawford
thank you brady
humanity has had a pretty good run so
far
in the last 200 years world gdp per
capita has increased by almost 14 times
but as they say past performance may not
be indicative of future results
can growth continue
one argument against long-term growth is
that we will run out of resources
malthus worried about running out of
farmland jevons warned that britain
would run out of coal and hubert called
peak oil
fears of shortages lead to fears of
overpopulation
if resources are static then they have
to be divided into smaller and smaller
shares for more and more people
in the 1960s this led to dire
predictions of famine and depredation
but predictions of catastrophic
shortages virtually never come true
agricultural productivity has grown
faster than malthus realized was
possible and oil production after a
temporary decline recently hit an
all-time high
one reason for this is that predictions
of shortages are based on conservative
estimates from only proven reserves
another is that when a resource really
is running out we transition off of it
as in the 1800s we switched our lighting
from whale oil to kerosene
but the deeper reason is that there's
really no such thing as a natural
resource all resources are artificial
they are a product of technology and
economic growth is ultimately driven not
by material resources but by ideas
in the 20th century the crucial role of
ideas was confirmed by formal economic
models
the economist robert solo was studying
how output per worker increases as we
accumulate capital such as machines and
factories
now what he found was there are
diminishing returns to capital
accumulation alone a single worker who's
given two machines can't be twice as
productive so if technology is static
output per worker soon stops growing
but
technology acts as a multiplier on
productivity
this makes each worker more productive
and creates more headroom for capital
accumulation
so we can have economic growth if and
only if we have technological progress
now how does this happen well another
economist paul romer pointed out the key
feature of ideas in economic terms they
are non-rival
unlike a loaf of bread or a machine an
invention or an equation can be shared
by everyone
now if we double the number of workers
we have and double the machines they use
we will merely double their output which
is the same output per worker but if we
also double the power of technology we
will more than double output making
everyone richer
physical resources have to be divided up
so as the population grows the per
capita stock of resources shrinks but
ideas do not the per capita stock of
ideas is the total stock of ideas
so we won't run out of resources as long
as we keep generating new ideas
but will we run out of ideas
now romer assumed that the technology
multiplier would grow exponentially at a
rate proportional to the number of
researchers
but soon after that another economist
chad jones pointed out that in the 20th
century we have vastly increased r d
while growth rates have been flat or
even declining
and this is evidence that ideas have
been getting harder to find
does this mean some inevitable
stagnation
maybe we've already picked all the
low-hanging fruit
maybe research is like mining for ideas
and the vein is running thin
maybe inventions are like fish in a pond
and the pond is getting fished out
but notice something about all these
metaphors they all treat ideas like
physical resources
and i think it's a mistake to call peak
ideas just as it seems to have always
been a mistake to call peak resources
one reason for this as paul romer
pointed out is that the space of ideas
is combinatorially vast
the number of potential molecular
compounds or the number of possible dna
sequences is astronomical
we have barely begun to explore
and even as ideas get harder to find we
get better at finding them
as the population and the economy grow
we can devote more brains and more
investment to r d
and technologies like spreadsheets or
the internet make researchers more
productive
in fact the greatest threat to long-term
economic growth might be the slowdown in
population growth
without more brains to push technology
forward progress might stall
now that's a problem for another time
i've only got five minutes here but note
that in those five minutes we've gone
from worrying about overpopulation to
underpopulation
and that's because we've traded a
scarcity mindset where growth is limited
by resources for an abundance mindset
where it is limited only
by our ingenuity
thank you all and uh thanks to brady and
the long now for this opportunity
thanks jason can you share the idea that
you're most excited about
for future growth oh there's so many um
but you know one of the biggest ones is
longevity if we can solve longevity that
gives us the time to solve uh many many
other problems
and that would certainly solve the
population problem
it would help yes
all right thank you very much jason
yeah
well
that was just a great ignite i want to
thank
all the speakers
uh for coming out and submitting
themselves to this torturous uh yet very
efficient format
and i want to thank the long now this is
our nth time doing this together and i
really appreciate working with all of
you especially
everyone who touched this directly
danielle justin andrew cameron and
xander
and then finally thanks to all of you uh
i hope you enjoyed the program let me
know what you think and if you want to
do an ignite
hit me up
thank you everyone that was amazing i
really appreciate all of you joining us
in this format and having so many member
speakers be part of this series i also
want to thank our host brady forest as
well as our whole crew thank you so much
have a good night
[Music]